[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le set
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
premier numéro de l'année 2018 tout de
suite le sommaire les super-héros
versaillais ont leur propre bande
dessinée l'association de bd et le nam
comics nous présentera leur nouvel
ouvrage le cinquième tome réalisées par
les artistes membres sortira le 13
janvier le président de l'association
nous en parlera elle a fait de l'eau sa
source d'inspiration sylvie poirson
expose ses toiles plus vrai que nature à
l'hôtel de ville de guyancourt elle est
à découvrir jusqu'au 3 février et qui
dit nouvelle année dit aussi cartes de
voeux c'est la tradition et pour 2018
pas question d'y échapper
mélanie nous montrera comment réaliser
une personnelle entrer dans la galerie
xi star wars version tricot il en aura
fallu de la force mais aussi de la
persévérance aux habitants de galles lui
pour monter leur exposition une centaine
de caisses en tricot sur le thème de la
célèbre saga des personnages
emblématiques au vaisseau les petites
mains d'une trentaine de participants se
sont activés c'est à découvrir jusqu'à
fin janvier dans la cour de la mairie
en décembre nous avions reçu les
organisatrices de l'événement écouter
suivant l'actualité je me suis dit on va
surprendre avec star wars personne va
nous attendre de ce côté là et donc gelé
soumis aux participants qui ont tous été
très emballé alors que la plupart
d'entre nous n'avait pas vu les films
même si on ne sait pas tricoter mais
qu'on s'est projeté ou faire du point de
croix où l'idée c'était vraiment de
d'optimiser les compétences qu'elle
quelle soit d'autre que chacun trouve sa
place et tout le monde l'a trouvé et
c'est extraordinaire comme aventure
humaine c'est un monument de la
littérature entre se valent entre romans
de chevalerie et roman comique
j'aurais pas me centrer mais on va y
arriver quand même deux t-shirts prendra
vie sur les planches du prisme le 12
janvier un spectacle créé par la
compagnie des dramaticules qui rend
hommage à l'oeuvre de miguel de
cervantes tout en affirmant son côté
burlesque
la preuve en images avec un extrait du
teaser
[Musique]
je
m
mais
vous
[Musique]
on connaît tous batman spider man les
personnages mythiques de marvel ou dc
comics mais à versailles aussi on a nos
propres super-héros barney midnight the
doc magic ce sont les lots nan heroes
réalisées par les artistes de
l'association et le nam comics son
président est avec nous bonjour nicolas
hamonou plus connu sous l'appellation de
hache nico n'est ce pas parce que vous
êtes également dessinateur et ses héros
dont on a parlé justement il existe
depuis déjà quelques années vous sortez
le 13 janvier le cinquième tome de leur
aventure c'est ça mon avocat me donc le
treizième tome des lots nani rose qui
est en fait une revue collective voilà
lundi 5 janvier hauteur donc des
histoires que je scénarise entièrement
et puis à tour de rôle on se passe les
crayons pour mettre en images un univers
cohérent de super héros qui ont la
propre style indépendante mais qui sont
amenés à se croiser au fil des épisodes
hall entendent aussi des
expérimentations un peu cimpor n'a ici
un roman photo
voilà donc c'est l'équipe de lausanne
qui s'est en fait mise en scène dans une
aventure et docks magic qui se retrouve
propulsé dans d'autres qui sont leur
propre héros je voulais retrouver votre
dimension
voilà donc ce genre de
de fantaisie un petit peu humoristique
mais qui ne fait pas pour autant de
cette bande dessinée parodie ce sont les
trams très sérieuse avec les personnages
un petit peu décalé d'accord et donc
vous est ce que vous nous les présenter
un petit peu ces héros se barre mais
c'est ça alors si et barney donc
l'association et lausanne a commencé
effectivement avec le bar n'est donc qui
est un chasseur de monstres donc
d'ascète cet aspect dans que gros bras
qui affrontent des créatures maléfiques
il ya aussi une petite ram secondaire
qui vont entre lecteurs et aux
personnages qu'elle est véritablement ce
ne sont pas forcément ceux que l'on
pense et c'est au tour de barney donc
dont l'intégrale des quatre aventures
qui ont été publiés depuis 2011 par
l'association et lausanne en je dis quoi
je me suis rien dans la froide en fait
monsieur barney donc voilà donc il est
lui c'est un chasseur de créatures c'est
ça alors après qu'est-ce qu'on a
d'autres parce que du coup j'ai cité
minant de bornes et voilà c'est vrai je
voulais revenir merci c'est que autour
d'une barre de barney on a développé une
écurie de personnages donc que l'on
retrouve dans la publication et la rose
donc on a au choix le dock magic que
vous avez cités en début de l'émission
la bestiole qui est une sorte de dôme
insectes hop là je préfère penser un
petit peu spiderman ci n'était pas
alcoolique et
qui ne fait pas qu un pompier 140 heroes
c'est ça complètement le ultra charrues
c'est une fin un anti héros c'est un
vampire chasseur de vampires donc là on
arriveront dans la gamme des personnages
un peu plus dérangeant va dire les
midnight donc spectre et scratch qui ont
des pseudos tellement ridicule que la
mafia se moque de chaque à chacune de
leurs apparitions et bang enfin un
cyborg qui se réveille amnésique dans
une décharge un beau soir d'été et qui
tuent les criminels son passage qui
cherche son passé au fil des épisodes
vous le disiez vous n'êtes pas tout seul
pour faire danser tous ces héros alors
est ce que vous nous présenter votre
association et les membres de
l'association donc l'association comme
l'avait dit existe depuis 2011
j'ai commencé donc en collaboration avec
un dessinateur de normandie donc il
répond au doux nom de
imanol d'un mec qui a été le premier à
collaborer avec moi pour lancer
l'aventuré lausanne
ensuite on a été rejoint par une
dizaines de dessinateurs on est
maintenant une quinzaine de dessinateurs
un noyau actif de cinq auteurs donc
essentiellement imanol dame est que
pierre champion chemise et dayraut il y
en a plein donc comment vous est venue
l'idée de créer cette association
participe également à des festivals en
fait j'avais sort pouvoir jamais sorti
un album à compte d'auteur en 2010 donc
album de bande dessinée qui m'avait
permis de faire la tournée un petit peu
des festivals pour dédicacer le web et
sur place j'ai fait j'ai fait des
rencontres
qui ont permis en fait de voir que je
n'étais pas le seul en fait à essayer de
me faire connaître comme ça et puis
comme on dit l'union fait la force et
j'ai proposé à ses auteurs de se joindre
à moi l'association et lausanne pour
essayer de développer un truc en commun
et de nous montrer un petit peut être à
sa publication
alors d'où ça vient alors cette passion
la bande dessinée des comics plus
particulièrement ce que c'est un style
particulier même si à la base je suis
pas forcément fan que de comics puisque
moi j'ai commencé comme beaucoup de
monde avec les classiques genre tintin
et blake et mortimer que je viens encore
aujourd'hui et puis je
quand j'étais gamin je me nourrissais
des des revues strange donc c'était une
revue qui était bon marché qu'on trouve
facilement dans les kiosques à journaux
et comme c'était les premières l'étrange
été la première application a publié des
sauts des des personnages de chez marvel
en france et comme j'ai souvent je suis
plus un fan de strange que de marvel en
fait les personnages qu'on trouve
aujourd'hui dans les films marvel c'est
ce que je lisais moi quand j'étais gamin
quand je les ai strange est ce un peu
cette ambiance que je veux retrouver
dans mes faire retrouver dans mes
publications donc une heureuse au format
souple un prix abordable
il est des lectures qui conviennent à un
enfant à partir de 10 ans on va dire
ainsi qu'aux grands enfants jusqu'à jeu
capitale on arrive à la fin de notre
entretien on va quand même parler d'une
dernière publication à aborder alors qui
est qui va sortir alors ils s'agitent
et le nahd pocket qui est une
publication un petit peu particulière
puisqu'elle est réservé en fait aux
adhérents de l'association
donc vous pouvez souscrire l'association
pour une durée d'un an pour un tarif de
10 euros vous recevez en cadeau la
publication et l'inde pocket vous
bénéficiez de tarifs préférentiels dans
notre boutique et tous les trois mois un
tirage au sort est organisé par mes
adhérents pour but de faire gagner des
cadeaux un petit peu sympa des bd des
goodies des choses comme ça donc tout ça
à retrouver en tout cas merci mots voilà
donc nicolas la fosse on sur le site en
fait et le et lausanne comics point
blogspot point fr exactement il affiche
du coup en bas en bas de l'écran le site
internet vous pouvez retrouver toutes
les informations et toutes les
publications
merci beaucoup en tout cas devenue sur
votre plateau pour nous parler de votre
association
l'eau et s'amuse sylvie poirson à lapins
de manière réelle presque hypnotique des
toiles réaliste qu'elle peint au pastel
au détour de promenade
elle expose à des à l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt reportage de mélanie poker on
entendrait presque l'eau couler les
oeuvres de sylvie poirson donne une
sensation de réalité l'artiste bien vous
inscrire au pastel depuis une quinzaine
d'années pastelliste de renom je crois
que on a l'impression d'être vraiment
face à un vrai paysage presque
photographique
sylvie a été découverte à notre dernier
concours d'arts visuels arts talent ça
nous a permis d'avoir de nouvelles
découvertes et en effet sylvie poirson
fait partie de celles là
j'ai essayé plusieurs techniques habran
[Musique]
l'aquarelle
un petit peu d'acrylique et j'ai essayé
le pastel après cette technique me
convenait beaucoup plus de par son côté
velouté et sensuelle en fait et ce qui
m'intéressait c'était vraiment d'avoir
le contact direct avec la matière avec
le pastel n'y a pas d'intermédiaire
l'eau rencontré au détour de promenade
l'inspirent
des instants où elle n'hésite pas à
installer son chevalet en pleine nature
une création en constante évolution
c'est vraiment l'élément justement dans
lequel je me sens bien je me déplace
beaucoup
dans des endroits où l'eau est présente
que ce soit en bord de mer donc avec les
milieux marins et aussi bien
dans des endroits où c'est plus des
rivières des cours d'eau paisible
jusqu'à présent je vais travailler de
manière très réaliste et alors
maintenant mon souhait c'est d'aller
justement vers quelque chose de moins
réalistes en gardant ce thème de l'eau
qui vraiment me passionne mer agitée lui
saute tranquille sylvie poirson
représente l'eau dans tous ses états
mais chaque oeuvre donne une sensation
de repos de plénitude mois de janvier
c'est la tradition se souhaite la bonne
année avec des voeux alors ya plusieurs
manières de le faire par sms ou par mail
mais le meilleur moyen c'est quand même
de recevoir une jolie carte
mélanie vous allez nous donner quelques
idées oui un moyen là aussi très
personnelle de présenter ses voeux alors
elle est très simple la carte que j'ai
fait ça avec dès tout petit renne
l'idéal ssl d'andria sur au droit ou
venir alors ça faire dès l'âge de 3 ans
et en plus ça demande très peu de
matériel regarder il faut de la peinture
un tube de colle des feutres un rouge et
un noah et des feuilles de format a4 de
papier légèrement cartonné moi j'ai
choisi des teintes marron à une foncé et
une bien plus claire une première étape
le découpage
j'ai choisi de fermer petit renne sur la
feuille à la plus claire je plie la
feuille a4 en deux on va voir les étapes
et je découpe là avec les mains il n'y a
pas besoin de ciseaux c'est pour ça
qu'on peut faire tout petit pour que ça
coûte bien par contre il faut bien
appuyé sur la pliure et je collerais
plus tard cette découpe sur la feuille
marron donc pour la rendre plus petit
là aussi je découpe les bords pas de
taille précise c'est vous qui choisissez
et on passe ensuite à la partie la plus
amusante et oui parce qu'on arrive au
moment où on va mettre les doigts dans
la peinture alors si vous avez de la
peinture marron prenez-la telquel moi je
suis une petite popote avec un monde
dès que je gauche pardon j'ai pris un
petit peu de peinture et si on m'avait
vous le voyez j'ai fait quatre tâches
plutôt vers le haut alors vous pouvez
faire plus grosse ou pas en fonction des
doigts que vous re de la taille de vos
doigts alors attention c'est de la
peinture ça peut ça peut glisser faux
fait près de faut être très précis en
plus après pardon vous la mettez de côté
pour laisser sécher vous prenez la
feuille marron je vais rattraper ça va
un peu plus vite vous la plier en deux
pour former la carte vous mettez de la
colle sur la première page et kohl et lé
petit renne dessus et pour terminer bien
sûr vous inscrivez dessus la nouvelle
année 2018 et pourquoi pas un petit mot
alors les rênes comment ce qu'on les
fait du coup fait la toute dernière
étape
est-ce que vous avez déjà fait les
petits dessins et vous allez prendre
avec votre feutre noir dessiné les bois
et les yeux puis le petit stylo rouge va
servir à faire un petit rond qui fera là
et selon vos envies il est également
possible de faire d'autres formes alors
là on va les montres et bijoux et ses
montres et mélanie à l'écran vous avez
également réalisé un sapin et un
bonhomme de neige
voilà mes loisirs fait avec les doigts
donc chacun peut laisser libre cours à
sa créativité merci en tout cas mélanie
meilleurs voeux pour cette année 2018 si
beau si on passe maintenant à notre
agenda avec deux derniers rendez vous à
noter
l'exposition archi cap la joue les
prolongations à versailles vous avez
encore jusqu'au 14 janvier pour
découvrir les reproductions des plus
célèbres monuments européens en briques
cap la tour eiffel la tour de pise ou
encore big ben et après les fêtes de fin
d'année place à la gourmandise
l'épiphanie c'est ce samedi 6 janvier
dimanche
comme le veut donc la tradition ce sera
le moment de déguster la galette des
rois
je vous souhaite donc une bonne
dégustation en famille et merci de nous
avoir suivis pour ce premier numéro de
l'année 2018
je retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]